[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur TV 78 pour
votre nouvelle émission le 7 8 nous
sommes le mercredi 26 octobre voici à le
programme elles seront installées en
nombre dans les prochaines semaines
baptisé startsky à 50 nouveaux points de
recharge public seront proposés aux
utilisateurs les bornes déjà présentes à
moropa Coignières plaisir et Villepreux
vont être adaptés et modernisés
l'objectif de 50 ans en Yvelines 200
bornes d'ici la fin de l'année 2023
santé une maison médicale vient d'être
inaugurée dans la commune de Maule elle
aura pour objectif de pallier au risque
d'une pénurie de médecins dans cette
zone rurale de 13000 habitants cette
ouverture a été soutenue par le
Département plus d'informations dans ce
7 8 avec le maire de la commune Laurent
Richard également vice-président à la
santé au débarquement
et enfin nous allons vous raconter
l'histoire de deux amis d'enfance
Pierre-Olivier et Timothée ses gourmand
ont décidé en 2015 de lancer leur propre
phase fabrication de cookies artisanaux
7 ans plus tard ils sont une dizaine à
faire tourner l'entreprise nous vous
ferons entrer dans les coulisses de
l'entreprise et avec moi sur ce plateau
Bertrand coca bonsoir alors vous êtes le
vice-président en charge de la Smart
City de l'énergie à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ensemble nous
allons parler de ce lancement des bornes
de recharge de véhicules électriques à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines avec plaisir
avec plaisir dans quelques instants avec
nous également Mathilde Franco bonsoir
alors vous allez nous présenter dans un
instant les informations à retenir de ce
jour dans les Yvelines de trottinette
électrique et aussi d'un parc de loisirs
alpin qui va bientôt ouvrir ses portes
céline est également avec nous sur ce
plateau journaliste de tv78 alors Céline
avec vous on va parler cinéma oui je
vous ai fait une petite sélection de
quatre films sortis aujourd'hui alors
horreur trailer
thriller pardon il y en aura pour tous
les goûts et en seconde partie
d'émission nous aurons en interview la
police municipale de Triel-sur-Seine
elle organise une sensibilisation aux
violences conjugales mais avant je vous
propose de jeter un petit coup d'œil à
la météo de demain
[Musique]
quel temps fera-t-il dans les Yvelines
ce jeudi il fera plutôt beau dans les
Yvelines le ciel sera partiellement
couvert dans le Nord et le Sud du
département les températures seront
plutôt douces pour la saison le matin il
fera 16 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie et
Versailles 15° à Houdan et Rambouillet
l'après-midi le temps sera également
couvert sur l'ensemble du département de
Rambouillet à Mantes-la-Jolie on pourra
sortir en T-shirt l'après-midi il fera
22 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie 21 degrés à
Rambouillet des températures bien
au-dessus des normales de saison et
demain nous fêterons la sainte Émeline
le point maintenant sur l'actualité du
jour dans les Yvelines avec vous
Mathilde c'est parti
on commence comme d'habitude par notre
chiffre du jour 65000 pourquoi
65000 Michael c'est le nombre
d'utilisateurs de trottinettes
électriques à Saint-Quentin en Yvelines
depuis mai 2021 et selon le responsable
du développement du groupe tiers
mobilité cela représente un bon bilan
écouté un véritable succès tire a
dépassé plus d'un million de trajets ici
sur l'agglomération de 50 ans en
Yvelines un million 200000 trajets pour
être précis réalisé par plus de 65000
utilisateurs
usagers uniques c'est un taux de
pénétration de 28% par rapport à la
population 50e et un taux de pénétration
de 70% par rapport à la population cible
c'est à dire les personnes entre 15 et
45 ans
et pendant la pénurie de carburant le
nombre d'utilisations de trottinettes
électriques à augmenter de 20% elles
sont aujourd'hui disponibles dans 40
communes des Yvelines mais le groupe
tiers mobility souhaite se développer
par la suite les salariés du site
L'Oréal à Rambouillet était en grève
aujourd'hui face à l'inflation il
demande une augmentation de leur salaire
de 4 à 5 % sur les 250 salariés du site
ils étaient une cinquantaine à faire
grève aujourd'hui devant les grilles du
groupe industriel français de
cosmétiques en début d'année la
direction avait accordé une hausse des
salaires de 2,6% mais c'est insuffisant
selon la CGT et la CFDT d'autres usines
de L'Oréal étaient en grève aujourd'hui
comme dans l'Aisne et la somme faire du
ski dans les Yvelines c'est insolite et
surtout bientôt possible Mathilde et oui
Michael un immense parc de loisirs sur
le thème des sports d'hiver va ouvrir le
1er novembre sur l'île des
Impressionnistes de Chatou au programme
piste de luge de plus de 4 mètres de
haut et de 25 mètres de long une piste
de ski sur un tapis roulant 170 cabines
téléphériques pour savourer une bonne
raclette ou une fondue le célèbre
patineur Philippe Candeloro vice
champion du monde de patinage artistique
présentera également 12 spectacles
jusqu'au 29 janvier mais à l'heure de la
soubriété à énergétique à un prôner ce
projet est-il vraiment raisonnable
Mathilde
habitants se posent les organisateurs
l'assurent ce projet consomme 10 fois
moins que Disney où le Parc Astérix la
patinoire est optimisée pour consommer
un minimum d'énergie et les pistes de
luge et de ski seront sur un revêtement
synthétique on termine par l'image du
jour Mathilde c'est là composition de
l'équipe de France féminine de rugby qui
joue actuellement on le sait tous la
Coupe du Monde en Nouvelle-Zélande
effectivement Michael une composition
qui nous concerne puisque livelinoise
Emily Boulard et de nouveau titulaires
régulièrement après avoir joué les
matchs de poules contre l'Afrique du Sud
et les Fidji la native de Rambouillet
sera sur le terrain pour le quart de
finale contre l'Italie la place en
demi-finale qui se jouera ce samedi 29
octobre à 5h du matin il va falloir
mettre le réveil très trop très tôt
Michael pour supporter les bleus et
cette yvelinoise qui a déjà inscrit au
deux essais dans cette compétition
vous aussi vous allez mettre le réveil
absolument il faut soutenir
ça se développe beaucoup voilà très très
content de le suivre merci Mathilde en
tout cas pour ces informations retenir
pour cette journée du 26 octobre et si
vous aussi vous voulez vous voyez une
info ou une image qui vous a marqué près
de chez vous dans les Yvelines n'hésitez
pas à nous la partager sur Twitter avec
le hashtag 7 8 news c'est tout nouveau
donc n'hésitez pas je
[Musique]
je le disais tout à l'heure en début
d'émission 50 ans en Yvelines va
déployer des nouvelles bornes de
recharge pour les voitures électriques
il y aura 50 nouveaux points d'ici fin
2023 le projet est baptisé starts ski
Bertrand Cauca vous êtes le
vice-président en charge de la Smart
City et de l'énergie à 50 ans en
Yvelines on va parler avec vous de ce
lancement alors avant de parler du
chiffre est-ce que c'est borne était une
demande on peut le dire de la population
locale alors c'était une demande surtout
de de l'utilisation des villes
puisqu'elles étaient pas vraiment et
également réparti parce qu'il n'y avait
que comme un cas de villes alors oui il
y a une grosse demande sur les
l'utilisation des bornes électriques
dans le domaine public puisque la
majorité des personnes se rechargent
chez elles mais il y a encore beaucoup
de personnes qui ne disposent pas de ces
bornes là et bien sûr pour nous c'est
très important de participer à la
réduction du gaz à effet de serre dans
nos villes et de pouvoir reprendre la
main effectivement sur le déploiement de
ces bandes publiques et notamment dans
un objectif d'attractivité
une entreprise ou du territoire sur les
commerces également le projet était dans
les cartons depuis longtemps le projet
était dans les cartons depuis deux ans
et demi à peu près on a fait une expert
première expérience il y a eu 36 points
de charge sur les quatre villes dont on
a parlé et on a vu que le taux
d'utilisation était pas forcément comme
on le souhaitait et on pensait qu'il
fallait complémenter cet offre il
fallait faire des choses un petit peu
différentes à nouveau Luc la relancer et
la mettre sur toutes les villes donc
c'est le bon moment aujourd'hui avec le
prix de l'essence et les besoins en
électriques et comment ça fonctionne
concrètement alors nouvel offre nouveau
look nouveau service nouveau prix
concrètement vous allez avoir les bornes
actuelles qui vont être effectivement
Relizane avec un bon évidemment ça parle
à notre génération
startsky ça fait un peu Starsky et Hutch
évidemment donc très identifiable donc
c'était aussi avec l'idée ou non c'est
les services alors je dirais le nom de
la personne mais en tout cas ça nous a
beaucoup plu de partir là-dessus et les
premiers retours sur les publicités on
envoie un petit peu partout son très
favorables alors il y a la possibilité
d'avoir Trois Bornes différentes d'abord
il faut savoir que ça s'adresse pas que
pour les voitures mais également vous
pouvez recharger les vélos vous pouvez
également recharger les motos parce
qu'on a de plus en plus de motos
électriques donc ça c'est très
intéressant Trois Bornes une recharge
direct classique je vais pas rentrer
dans les détails mais qui prennent entre
deux et trois heures maximum une
recharge un petit peu plus rapide et une
recharge très rapide qui va concerner
plutôt la les zones d'entreprise qui ne
sont pas encore en déploiement mais qui
devrait être déployer d'ici un an un an
et demi oui les non standard express et
boost c'est ça exactement
par exemple les super charger ou les
lions Unity donc nous n'aurons oserons
c'est du même niveau absolument ça
permet de recharger très rapidement
l'une des meilleurs 45 minutes et c'est
très important encore une fois pour
l'attractivité du territoire pour les
gens qui se déplacent s'arrêtent à 50
ans consomment sur Saint-Quentin ou en
vont à l'entreprise à 50 ans en Yvelines
se recharge rapidement et repartent du
territoire j'ai vu également -30% pour
ceux qui recherchent la nuit absolument
aujourd'hui vous savez que tous les
mondes recherchent à peu près en même
temps donc c'est intéressant aussi de
pouvoir le faire donc les tarifs très
simple 30 centimes du kilowattheure pour
la borne standard 60 centimes pour la
borne effectivement que l'on appelle
L'Express qui permet de recharger
rapidement en une heure une heure et
demie et la nuit entre 22h et 8h du
matin - 30 % donc c'est et puis vous
n'aurez pas de majoration parce que l'on
souhaite qu'effectivement les personnes
ne se gare pas là pendant trois ou
quatre heures on souhaite à bonne
rotation importante donc il va y avoir
une majoration si vous allez au-delà de
3 heures de charge vous aurez une
majoration ce sera pas le cas la nuit
donc la nuit effectivement de 8h à de
pardon de minuit à 8h du matin 30% de
réduction donc 30 centimes d'euros et
les bornes seront installées dans toutes
les communes de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines oui absolument
parce que pour l'instant il y avait
morpa Coignières plaisir et Villepreux
là ce sera partout ce sera partout très
rapidement deux bornes minimum dans
chaque ville ça c'est l'objectif le plus
rapide et à terme vous l'avez mentionné
200 points de charge en 2023
des problèmes d'humilité le manque
d'étanchéité sur ces 2ème génération là
nous avons réglé le problème donc on
aura des bornes un petit peu plus
pérennes et combien ça coûte à 50 ans en
Yvelines ce dispositif alors on va le
passer dans le budget l'idée c'est qu'on
soit à peu près à coup équilibré bien
sûr il y a un investissement qui est
fait dans plus de 100000 € pour vous
donner les ordres d'idées par contre en
terme de fonctionnement on devrait
pouvoir rentrer dans notre coup si nous
suivons le modèle que nous voulons qui
est par un modèle de excessif en termes
de recharge je pense que ça va bien
fonctionner la demande est là et donc ça
devrait pas à terme coûter beaucoup plus
que ça aux usagers pour bénéficier d'un
service je dirais très pratique concret
on l'a dit à 200 bornes d'ici 2023
est-ce qu'il y en aura encore plus dans
dans les années à venir au-delà 2023 on
regardera sur la sur la demande
évidemment un bilan qui sera fait on
regardera sur les bandes qu'on appelle
2.0 dans lequel vous allez pouvoir aussi
interagir avec des données avec pourquoi
pas de à partir de la bande pour pouvoir
cons quelles sont les derniers films et
pouvoir interagir donc c'est un petit
peu ça l'avenir c'est pas que les bornes
de recharge mais il peut y avoir des
bornes interactives très intéressantes
alors en tout cas si vous voulez plus de
renseignements vous pouvez vous
connecter sur le site de 50 ans en
Yvelines 50 ans en yvelines.fr merci
Bertrand Cauca on vous garde encore
quelques instants avec nous dans cette
émission où il faut réagir sur plusieurs
sujets dans quelques instants alors on
va maintenant parler d'une initiative
lancée par l'entreprise orange lors de
l'université des mairies de l'Ouest
parisien mi-octobre affirme à signer des
conventions avec des petites communes du
département objectif récupérés des
téléphones portables
usagers pour les recycler au total une
vingtaine de communes de l'Ouest
parisien participe à cette opération il
y a par exemple la commune d'orphins on
écoute Jean-Luc Giraud nous présente le
concept au micro de TV 78 ils ont un
site Web qui leur est dédié on a signé
une convention avec eux
ils y vont ils commandent la boîte la
boîte leur est livrée sur place il la
met dans leur commune à l'endroit qui
vole 30 ans ils font des partenariats
avec une école pour faire une animation
ponctuelle d'une journée ou lors des
journées des associations sur des
actions de recyclage au niveau de la
commune et dès que cette boîte est
pleine donc ils mettent cette boîte les
gens mettent leur téléphone leur fil qui
vont avec leur chargeur et dès que la
boîte est pleine et ben ils vont sur le
site web ils disent la boîte est pleine
et quelqu'un vient chercher la boîte en
conséquence et leur donne une nouvelle
boîte vide pour pouvoir de nouveau
répéter cette opération
on va maintenant parler de cette maison
médicale inaugurée dans la commune de
Maule nous sommes sur ce plateau et que
Laurent Richard le maire de la commune
est conseillé départemental
vice-présidents délégué à la santé
bonsoir bonsoir alors on va tout de
suite parler de cette inauguration à
Meaux l'avant-parler de parler plus
globalement de cette désertification
médicale sur le territoire des Yvelines
vous êtes un mère ravi j'imagine après
cette inauguration l'inauguration
officielle a eu lieu samedi dernier je
le rappelle
absolument bien sûr ravie elle avait
ouvert ses portes déjà au début mais en
montant en puissance en quelques mois et
maintenant elle tourne à plein régime
pratiquement et
ravi parce que c'est
6 ans 7 ans de travail de préparation
pour arriver à ce résultat quoi et
comment les constituer du coup cette
maison médicale alors combien de
médecins à l'intérieur et là elle est
prévue pour avoir six médecins généraux
5 médecins généralistes un interne
généraliste 1 et 3 3 spécialistes qui se
succéderont de l'hôpital des poissons
particulièrement mais aussi de ment et
de Meulan et qui se succéderont dans le
même cabinet mais on n'a pas besoin
d'avoir des spécialistes absolument à
plein temps dans le bassin de santé de
Maule et nous avons nous avons aussi une
infirmière une IPA c'est une infirmière
en pratique avancée ça c'est extrêmement
intéressant notamment pour ceux qui ont
des thérapies à suivre en matière de
cancer chimio et autres et puis nous
aurons nous avons déjà trois médecins
trois dentistes pardon trois chirurgiens
dentistes on a trois paramédicaux
orthophonistes podologue etc et on a
quatre quatre infirmières également
enfin on a installé dans la maison
médicale un laboratoire d'analyses
médicales et à l'étage on partage
l'étage avec le territoire d'action
départementale qui qui gère
essentiellement disons l'action sociale
du départemental du département dans
tout ce secteur donc il y a une synergie
aussi assez forte c'était une demande de
vos administrés
ils ont parlé souvent peut-être sur le
terrain non non très honnêtement on est
anticipé par rapport à eux ils n'en
parlait pas encore quand je vous dis que
ça fait 6 ou 7 ans qu'on travaille
dessus on anticipé et grâce
aux praticiens aux professionnels de
santé qui étaient effectivement à Maule
ils sont pris conscience effectivement à
la fois de de l'âge de la retraite qui
acquise qui qui s'approchait pour les
uns et les autres et donc il voyait
venir le désert médical sachant très
bien qu'ils avaient énormément de
problèmes pour ceux qui déjà recherchés
il y a 5 ans à trouver le moindre
successeur
donc ils nous ont alertés et ils l'ont
fait très intelligemment dans ce sens
que ils ont constitué et moi je les ai
encouragé à le faire une association qui
s'appelle jamesoni amole entre eux et on
a utilisé donc
cette association et leur présence bien
sûr pour les leur faire partager toute
la préparation de cette maison médicale
donc tout l'agencement avec le
dans la liste du département qui nous
aidait bien entendu au niveau de
l'architecture intérieure j'entends bien
et donc la fonctionnalité finalement de
l'établissement et ça plane utilité
cette maison médicale va s'avérer
environ 13000 personnes d'après les
chiffres que j'ai peut-être un peu plus
moi je vais lui ça au moins 15000
personnes parce que les chiffres dont on
dispose ont toujours un peu de retard
sur la réalité c'est ce que ce que
représente le bassin de santé de mon
effectivement alors il y a une baisse de
plus de 20% du nombre de médecins
généralistes dans les Yvelines en 10 ans
comment vous l'expliquez
très simplement baisse du numéro de
clausus volontaire de la part
effectivement de gouvernements il y a
une qui a commencé je dirais il y a
presque une trentaine d'années mais
c'est surtout il y a 20 ans
et
non seulement baise du closus mais
des locaux qui deviennent bien sûr
insuffisants pour augmenter aujourd'hui
ce numéro exclusif dans les façons d'une
façon assez importante des locaux je
veux dire universitaires et croyant tout
cela
stupidement je dirais très honnêtement
baisser le déficit de la Sécurité
sociale en disant s'il y a moins de
médecins il y aura moins d'ordonnance
purement de médicaments etc donc on aura
moins d'actes et moins de et moins de
dépenses médicament et donc on lutte
c'est une façon de lutter contre le
difficile la sécurité nationale sociale
pension nous il y a il y a plus de 20
ans attention pensait nous gouvernante
grosse erreurs bien entendu puisque je
suis pratiquement c'est pas l'inverse
enfin aujourd'hui ça a produit
c'est facile de dire on économise en
matière de buteur ne soyons plus les
gens ce qui se passe
donc ça a été une très mauvaise décision
donc c'est véritablement la conséquence
ils arrivent à la retraite et il y a
personne derrière il n'a pas assez donc
les nouveaux choisissent l'endroit où
ils vont aller
ils sont ils ont ils ont vraiment
l'embarras du choix et
peut-être un petit peu moins dans les
campagnes la campagne yvinoise alors la
campagne
elle est agréable mais encore faut-il
avoir envie d'y vivre et surtout en fait
les jeunes médecins aujourd'hui ont
envie de travailler en équipe de
travailler plutôt 35 heures que 70 comme
faisait leur prédécesseurs en faisant
des visites même le week-end et puis de
d'être dans l'échange au niveau de
diagnostic donc si il y a du fond aussi
derrière avoir un projet médical et puis
être dans l'échange au niveau de du
Mexique avec une avec une équipe tout en
étant en libéraux enfin libéral les les
tous les médecins qui sont à Maule sont
des libéraux ils continuent l'exercice
libéral mais mais bénéficie de la
proximité des autres du travail et il
manque des spécialistes aussi alors il
manque aussi des spécialistes on sait
tous pour les ophtalmo les dermatos par
exemple comprendre des des spécialités
de ce genre dans les dans les quotas
aussi ont été largement
réduits par par le ministère
mais
c'est moins c'est moins sensible dans
nos dans nos campagnes où il fallait
nous il fallait nous déplacer déjà assez
loin pour pouvoir bénéficier de
spécialistes d'y reproches du assez loin
pour nous c'est assez facile on n'est
pas loin de la vallée de la scène donc
pas loin de Poissy parlant de
Saint-Germain donc c'était assez simple
mais c'est le cas donc ben néanmoins
c'est important qu'il vienne ici et en
plus je pense ça on va être
gagnant-gagnant c'est à dire que ça va
permettre à l'hôpital de faire une
consultation avancée
une demi-journée ou une journée par
semaine pour certains de ses
spécialistes
dans le milieu rural et ça lui permet
effectivement aussi d'avoir
de d'être plus proche effectivement de
ça de sa patientèle potentielle et de de
rapatrier des actes de chirurgie par
exemple dans leur propre hôpitaux de
façon à ce que les hôpitaux tournent
mieux encore qu'il ne tourne
actuellement il pourrait améliorer
effectivement le le rendement des gros
investissements qui sont fait quand même
à l'hôpital au niveau chirurgical par
exemple dernière question il y a ces
maisons médicales mais est-ce que le
département oeuvre également sur
d'autres secteurs pour pour améliorer le
secteur de la santé alors bien sûr je
pense notamment à la télémé les maisons
médicales c'est fondamentale puisque en
fait c'est 32 millions qui sont
consacrés par le département ou sur 22
maisons médicales 9 sont déjà terminés
et en fonction et là Maul c'était la
première qui soit 100% départementale on
nous a délégué la maîtrise d'ouvrages on
nous l'ex à gestion mais elle a elle est
la propriété du département
qui permettent de compléter encore cette
offre cette offre de soins nouvelles
savoir que les maisons médicales
permettent d'avoir à peu près un tiers
de médecins qui existent déjà sur le
territoire mais deux tiers qui sont des
nouveaux médecins qui arrivent qui sont
qui sont soit de jeunes médecins soit
des médecins qui arrivent d'autres
territoires
pour nous pour nous rejoindre et là la
télémédecine va permettre effectivement
de monter cette offre de frein mais pour
des pour des bien sûr des des des des
des
des affections beaucoup plus banales
quoi une grippe un bobo voilà des choses
relativement simple telles qu'elles
viennent plus compliquées bien sûr que
le médecin qui sera qui sera derrière
l'écran prescrira bien sûr la rencontre
d'un généraliste
c'est très important c'est très bien
perçu par les médecins eux-mêmes parce
que ça va les décharger il faut savoir
que nous médecins déjà sont très très
chargés dans les maisons médicales donc
on va en mettre on va mettre une cabine
de télé médecine dans notre dans notre
maison médicale de Maule le département
va le faire et c'est très bien perçu ça
fera peut-être 1000 acte qui passeront
qui sont simples et qui passeront par
cette cabine de télémédecine et qui
viendront donc qui rentreront dans les
fichiers de de nos médecins ce qui
permettra aux médecins référentes
continuer à suivre parfaitement son
patient merci à vous à Laurent Richard
vice-président délégué à la santé au
département des Yvelines et maires de
Maule
[Musique]
l'entretien a été enregistré dans
l'après-midi Bertrand Coquard qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez de cette maison
médicale à Maule c'est essentiel le
département
s'engage effectivement auprès des
communes qui ont pas toujours les moyens
de pouvoir investir dans les maisons
médicales on sait que c'est ce qui
permet aux gens de rester de ne pas
partir ailleurs il y a un besoin médical
important peu importe la ville qu'elle
soit urbaine ou rurale c'est quelque
chose qui est important alors on met les
murs après il y a toujours la difficulté
effectivement d'avoir des médecins
puisque ça c'est toujours une pénurie
qui ne sera pas résolue donc le deuxième
étape la semaine dernière je me permets
un petit aparté la semaine dernière on a
signé au conseil départemental un appel
un projet pour la télémédecine sous
trois formats cabines dans ces maisons
médicales là donc ça permet
effectivement d'avoir la maison médicale
d'avoir le médecin directement connecté
ou des bornes dans les pharmacies ou
encore de la télémédecine avec une
petite mallette où les gens viendrai à
domicile donc c'est un complément idéal
le département aujourd'hui investi
puisque son département ce serait de
pouvoir donner des solutions donc ces
deux types de solutions maison médicale
mon collègue m'en apparence on a parlé
et cet appel d'offre qui devrait être
résolu d'ici à la fin d'année on devrait
pouvoir mettre ça en place donc connecté
le médecin dans la maison de médicale
avec un besoin très important
aujourd'hui on est en pénurie vous êtes
aussi conseil municipal aux
Clayes-sous-Bois est-ce que c'est un
problème que vous rencontrez aux
Clayes-sous-Bois oui absolument
aujourd'hui on a on a perdu des médecins
qui partaient à la retraite on a je
crois 5 médecins qui ont entre 60 et 65
ans donc ils vont partir à la retraite
il faut les remplacer il y a pas de
remplacement on a un projet de maison
médicale qui est important entre temps
on aura aussi c'était les cabines les
deux doivent fonctionner ensemble Merci
à VOUS Bertrand cocker je le rappelle
vous êtes entre autres vice-président
charges de la Smart City et de l'énergie
à Saint-Quentin en Yvelines est-ce que
vous êtes gourmand autour de cette table
Bertrand Coquard peut-être oui oui
gourmand pas entre les repas mais
pendant le repas oui et notamment le
chocolat Mathilde
parce que tout le monde le sait autour
de la République
mais entre les repas moi
allons parler d'une histoire formidable
c'est l'histoire de deux amis d'enfance
Pierre Olivier et Timothée c'est
gourmand ont décidé en 2015 de lancer
leur propre fabrication de cookies
artisanaux 7 ans plus tard ils sont une
dizaine à faire tourner l'entreprise on
vous fait découvrir les coulisses d'une
journée avec eux
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans notre
laboratoire de cookies artisanal des
Alluets-le-Roi nous allons vous proposer
une visite afin de voir comment se
prépare une pâte à cookies
nous avons ici Alexandre aujourd'hui en
production par exemple en train de faire
une pâte au caramel beurre salé dans un
robot ici présent qui nous permet de
préparer en une seule fois
approximativement mille cookies vous
avez sa table de travail son frigo dans
lequel il stock c'est eux son beurre et
vous avez actuellement donc la dresseuse
qui est en route qui nous permet de
peser précisément des petits pâtons aux
poire requêtés avant de passer au
dressage des plaques de cuisson
vous avez donc à ce titre ni Nelly ici
présente qui est en train de dresser des
brookies donc un dérivé de notre pâte à
cookies un format 120 g carré très
généreux et qui propose donc de préparer
ces grilles sur une échelle à
destination du four ici présent qui nous
permet de cuire 300 cookies toutes les
10 15 minutes
[Musique]
il a important effectivement de vérifier
la cuisson en fin de process ça peut se
jouer à une ou deux minutes près et
effectivement pour vraiment arriver à la
texture qu'on souhaite proposer à nos
clients croustillant sur le dessus
fondant à l'intérieur on se doit d'avoir
une cuisson très précise et on a beau
avoir un Super Four très très fiable en
température et vraiment du top du top il
faut quand même être alerte sur les
dernières instants de cuisson pour être
certain d'être vraiment sur le produit
qu'on souhaite proposer à tous
démarrage en 2015 c'est deux amis
d'enfance donc pierre et Tim l'envie de
créer quelque chose de bon au départ
d'artisanal tous nos développements est
basé énormément sur les produits de
qualité le circuit court donc c'est au
départ une idée de se dire
voilà faire quelque chose de bon de
frais et 10 novembre aussi qu'on voit
pas partout vers chez nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
va chercher les œufs
[Musique]
salut Guillaume comment vas-tu
360 est prête on a nos 360 œufs du jour
c'est parfait on va pouvoir transformer
tout ça en cookies exactement
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on produit entre 2000 et
environ 2000 cookies par jour clairement
entre 1500 et 2000 ça va ça va rien un
petit peu donc on est sur une base de
entre 40 et 50 000 cookies par mois
l'objectif 2023 c'est de passer à 60 000
cookies par mois et 2024 de doubler donc
80000 coquis par mois on a plein de
petites pépites dans nos boutiques comme
du thé matcha du yuzu meringue cranberry
chocolat blanc en ce moment voilà on
essaie de de diversifier au maximum et
de s'adresser au plus de personnes à
tous les gourmands en tout cas
[Musique]
très beau reportage ça vous donne envie
de déguster Mathilde évidemment
on les a dégustés
à la bouche dans ce 7 8 on va parler de
fromage reblochon camembert et mental et
Français comptent parmi les plus gros
mangeurs de fromage et chaque année le
deuxième week-end d'octobre les Yvelines
accueille le plus grand festival de
fromage d'Île-de-France à Meulan en
Yvelines producteur traditionnel à finir
mais aussi viticulteurs viennent
présenter leur métier et leur produit
ils viennent de toute la France pour
célébrer le fromage à melon en Yvelines
et avec 300 variétés différentes il y en
a pour tous les goûts on propose de la
tomme fermière qui est l'atome de vache
de jerse au lait de jerse on a plusieurs
affinages on a une médaille d'argent en
Île-de-France et donc on a la tombe
jeune la tomme de printemps d'hiver la
tomme vieille ensuite on a plusieurs
produits frais comme des yaourts des
crèmes faire crème fraîche faisselle
fromage blanc fromage frais voilà à peu
près on a goûté quelques fromages moi
perso je n'aime pas le de fromage fort
j'aime bien ceux qui sont un petit peu
durs là pas dur donc du coup le chèvre
j'aime bien aussi on a pris de la Ligue
tout ça tout ça
et pour cette 27e édition ce sont les
Alpes qui sont mises à l'honneur
véritable rendez-vous pour les
professionnels avec une cinquantaine
d'exposants la plupart sont des
affineurs ou des producteurs cette
possibilité de faire connaître nos
produits aux consommateurs d'expliquer
ce qu'on fait d'expliquer nos métiers ça
c'est un vrai plaisir et cette année est
particulière puisque Meulan Yvelines a
obtenu le label année de la gastronomie
une distinction qui met en avant les
initiatives de valorisation de la
gastronomie sur tout le territoire on a
toujours à peu près 30 000 visiteurs sur
tout le week-end donc un gros succès et
puis des exposants fromage et vins qui
viennent de toute la France donc on est
très contents parce qu'on fidélise nos
exposants et on fidélise aussi nos
visiteurs
et ce sont plus de 300 000 morceaux de
fromage qui sont dégustés chaque année
durant le week-end
Mathilde Céline je vais vous poser la
question qui tue cookies au fromage
mais je pense que je dirais fromage
quand même pour vous Céline je suis
savoyarde donc fromage c'est sûr alors
maintenant ouvrir une page culture dans
ce 7 8 on va prendre la direction de
Chevreuse c'est un rendez-vous à noter
dans vos agendas c'est la deuxième
exposition du musée Grataloup depuis son
ouverture en mars 2022 les Fables de La
Fontaine le rêve de Lucas candle a
débuté le 12 octobre 2022 se prolongera
jusqu'au 27 février 2023 un reportage de
vous c'est une Charles
le corbeau fier et orgueilleux était
perché sur un arbre
le renard rusé et flatteur voulu lui
prendre son fromage le corbeau et le
renard la poule aux œufs d'or ou encore
le renard et la cigogne les Fables de La
Fontaine n'ont plus de secret pour
l'artiste peintre Lucas candle à travers
son exposition au musée Grataloup il
nous propose sa propre interprétation
des fables à travers une quinzaine de
toiles ça touche ce côté en paix de rêve
un peu imaginaire ça permet aux artistes
justement dans le domaine de la rampe et
fantastique de les interpréter chaque
artiste dans sa façon ce qui nous plaît
à ceux qui justement même les personnes
qui connaissent les femmes finalement
ils se disent tiens je l'ai imaginé
comme ça et finalement je la vois tout
petit peu métamorphoses par l'artiste
qui est expose ici chef de fil du
mouvement réaliste magique en France
Lucas scandale propose une vision
réaliste du monde moderne en y ajoutant
des éléments magiques fantastiques et
surréalistes un tableau aussi qui est le
conseil tenu par les rats moi je les ai
suspendus dans l'espace donc la cloche
représente finalement ce qui raconte
il faut suspendus par leur queue et donc
finalement il se balance ils sont
ensemble et finalement il règle leurs
problèmes de cette façon là tu
respectera je dirais que le résultat
c'est le rêve éveillait ce sont les
personnes qui
ont pas obligation de dormir pour
raconter leur rêve Lucas scandale est le
premier artiste invité au musée après
l'exposition ciel et terre du peintre
Grataloup qui a comptabilisé plus de 150
visiteurs par mois le fonctionnement il
est très simple c'est que nous allons
faire deux expositions par an donc une
nécessairement sur le peintre Grataloup
autour d'une thématique spécifique et
puis deuxième où nous aurons justement
un artiste invité l'artiste s'est lancé
le pari d'illustrer l'ensemble des
Fables de La Fontaine il en a déjà peint
plus de la moitié 90 fables restent
encore à réaliser
Céline vous avez tourné ce reportage
qu'est-ce que vous en avez pensé de
cette exposition mais c'est une très
jolie exposition qui plongent vraiment
dans un monde féérique et ce qui a de
bien c'est que nous fait redécouvrir
toutes les fables et celle notamment
celle qu'on ne connaissait pas voilà il
y en a beaucoup de connus mais il y en a
aussi qu'on ne connaissait pas et les
interprètent vraiment à sa manière comme
comme il le dit chaque artiste à sa
propre vision des choses et la sienne
était très très imagée très dans le rêve
dans l'imaginaire c'était très joli
on continue par un spectacle le public a
rendez-vous ce vendredi 28 octobre à
20h30 au Théâtre Octave Mirebeau à
Triel-sur-Seine pour une pièce de
théâtre mais c'est un spectacle
particulier intitulé je me porte bien
pour sensibiliser les participants
contre les violences conjugales une
initiative de la police municipale de la
commune pour en parler avec nous Pascal
Gilles maire adjoint à la sécurité à la
prévention atrielle sur scène et David
désiré directeur de la police municipale
à Triel-sur-Seine bonsoir messieurs
bonsoir alors nous accueillir alors
pourquoi vous êtes engagé sur cette
thématique c'était un sujet de campagne
qui nous tenait avec Monsieur le Maire
moi-même étant membre des forces de
l'ordre avant de rentrer sur la liste
municipale nous sommes au cœur du sujet
nous voyons malheureusement je dis bien
malheureusement une croissance des
féminicides et des violences faites aux
femmes donc on voulait nous apporter
notre petite pierre à l'édifice et
essayer de d'aider les femmes qui
étaient victimes à notre niveau local de
ces violences David des violences aussi
sur votre secteur ou pas forcément ça
peut être dans tout le département dans
toute la région toute la France sur
Triel c'est une ville tranquille et il y
a pas de plus qu'ailleurs mais
malheureusement comme ailleurs ça arrive
il y a des violences on intervient
régulièrement sur des différents
conjugaux différents familiaux et on ça
peut s'apercevoir des fois qu'il y a des
traces de coups donc oui c'est pas c'est
pas évident à traiter parce que la
personne est malheureusement souvent
dans le déni donc elle souhaite pas
toujours qu'on intervienne de la de la
façon la plus adaptée aux intervenez
vous en tant que police municipale on
est souvent les
primo arrivants c'est-à-dire que les
gens ont pris l'habitude de nous appeler
ça peut être les voisins ça peut être le
vin le voisin du tube du dessous ça peut
être qu'on va dire même quelqu'un de la
maison qui nous appelle et oui ça nous
arrive régulièrement qu'on interviennent
dans ce genre de situation Mathilde
pour faire passer un message qui soit le
plus perceptible par tous c'est pas
évident d'évoquer ce sujet
qui est assez dramatique donc il va
pouvoir faire passer le message que
vient ça existe et que aussi libérer la
parole de la part de ces femmes qui en
sont victimes qu'elles arrivent et leur
montrer qu'il y a des gens qui sont à
l'écoute des gens qui sont formés pour
apporter le lait de nécessaire parce que
c'est pas évident pour ces femmes de
franchir le pas et d'évoquer cette
problématique
la spécificité de cette pièce c'est que
l'auteur la c'est une policière c'est ça
d'accord et c'est ça c'était important
aussi pour vous que ça soit une
policière qui met en scène cette pièce
donc elle reçoivent directement donc les
plaintes de ces personnes et elles
peuvent voir les dommages aussi bien
physique et psychologiques que cela
engendre sur les femmes qui ont son
victime elle a créé d'ailleurs cette
pièce par rapport à tout ça tout ce
qu'elle a vu tout ce qu'elle a pu voir
au cours de sa carrière elle avait vu
quelques situations dramatiques comme
dit monsieur Gilles et c'est ce qui lui
c'est ce qu'il lui a poussé peut-être
une sorte d'exutoire parce que les
policiers prennent ça en pleine face et
après il faut rentrer à la maison et
faire avec donc il y en a qui vont faire
du sport d'autres qui font des
compétitions de choses ils essaient de
se changer les esprits et elle elle a
fait le choix de d'écrire d'écrire et de
faire cette pièce de théâtre
combien de personnes ont travaillé sur
cette pièce
Saunier Sonia il a et l'auteur et la
metteur en scène et donc il y a
l'actrice Caroline missback qui fait le
qui fait qui fait la pièce quoi donc ils
sont deux elles sont deux est-ce que
vous pouvez nous raconter un petit peu
l'histoire de cette pièce comment ça se
déroule c'est l'histoire d'une femme qui
s'appelle rose qui est jeune sportif
pleine de vie
qui rencontre son prince charmant et qui
se promet que c'est le seul et l'unique
qui n'aura pas d'autres c'est celui-là
et puis le temps va passer et puis la
violence va s'installer et elle va pas
pouvoir de se sortir ces situations je
vous raconte pas la fin de la pièce il y
a quand même il y a quand même une fin
mais
je laisse le spectateurs
venir et découvrir voilà mais oui oui
elle va expliquer la difficulté que
laisser personne là peuvent avoir à
s'extraire de cette emprise parce que
c'est clairement une emprise et avec une
emprise de psychologique des violences
sur la des violences physiques mais
aussi les violences psychologiques il
peut y avoir aussi des violences ce
qu'on appelle financières c'est tout
bête mais ne pas avoir accès à sa carte
bleue ne pas avoir accès à toutes ce
genre de choses pour garder l'emprise
sur cette personne elle devient
complètement dépendante sans s'en rendre
compte petit à petit ils l'isole de tout
ou de tout des amis de la famille et
elle devient complètement défendante
dépendante de son bourreau quand vous
avez monté ce spectacle ont été les
réactions autour de ce spectacle on va
être on va rester modeste on ne l'a pas
monté c'est c'est vraiment Sonia et qui
l'a fait on travaille en collaboration
avec une association qui s'appelle red
aventure organisation et qui est
association là travaille plus
étroitement qui propose cette pièce de
théâtre
aux communes qui souhaitent
mettre en oeuvre sur la sur leur commune
est-ce que vous avez prévu un débat
derrière tout à fait oui il y aura un
temps d'échange juste après la fin de la
séance d'accord vous attendez combien de
personnes à peu près vous savez ou pas
encore
comblés la salle le plus possible il y a
déjà pas mal de regarder mais il reste
encore des places vous pouvez encore
réserver il y a pas de souci il reste
encore des places Mathilde on sait que
c'est un sujet qui vous tient à cœur
parce que il me semble que les dimanches
vous proposez toujours un cours pour de
cette défense aux femmes pour qu'elles
puissent apprendre à se défendre
elle-même vous le faites toujours donc
depuis le début de notre mandat j'ai mis
ça en place et on propose c'est
totalement gratuit à toutes les
trielloises donc une session par mois
dimanche matin donc d'initiation à la
seule fois défense tout à fait
j'aurais pas le dire mais on a quelques
femmes de Verneuil et de Vernouillet
merci à tous les deux d'être passé je me
porte bien c'est ce vendredi 28 octobre
à 20h30 à Triel-sur-Seine on est
mercredi comme d'habitude nous allons
ouvrir une page cinéma vous le savez
tous on approche d'Halloween est-ce que
vous avez des films d'horreur à nous
recommander autour de cette table Céline
l'escrime incontournables je pense que
c'est tout le monde au moins vu un
utilisé par une femme et que celle-ci a
un grand talent
quatre jeunes adultes responsables
partent sur une île de Tasmanie l'île de
Tasmanie s'est située au large de
l'Australie et ce sont des gens
particulièrement raisonnables ils
connaissent tous les codes des films
horreurs ils savent ce qu'il ne faut pas
faire et voilà pourquoi le film devient
très intéressant c'est que les arriérés
qui vont s'en prendre à eux vont devoir
être plus malins que ces malins jeunes
gens
donc la course-poursuite est réelle
c'est un film évidemment inquiétant
qu'il faut déconseiller aux âmes
sensibles mais l'ambiance est
remarquable et les décors de ligne de
Tasmanie très peu connu sont absolument
remarquables on est dans une ambiance
inquiétante à souhait et le film
évidemment va aller de surprises en
surprise jusqu'à devenir malheureusement
ou heureusement pour les amateurs
totalement morts mais l'ensemble du
filtre reste extrêmement raisonnable et
pourtant très inquiète je vous
recommande Dying Bride 2018 ce film
australien d'horreur
avec le rire à la fin ça a l'air super
sympa mais quand même un petit peu un
petit peu gore quand même alors on
continue à parler d'Halloween avec vous
Céline Charles vous nous proposez de
découvrir les sorties cinéma de ce
mercredi je crois que pour le premier on
est on est dans le thème oui toujours
qu'il dit Halloween dit bien sûr vous
l'avez dit film d'horreur je ne pouvais
commencer ses sorties cinéma autrement
qu'avec un bon film qu'on aime regarder
pour se faire peur alors il s'agit du
film la proie du diable du réalisateur
Daniel Stam donc c'est un film qui
explore une nouvelle facette de
l'exorcisme c'est l'entraînement
intensif de religieux prêt à se battre
contre les démons histoire est plutôt
simple selon les archives du Vatican les
cas de possession démoniaque on
considérablement augmenté ces dernières
ces dernières années pour y faire face
l'Église catholique à secrètement
réouvert les écoles d'exorcisme c'est
une jeune non soeur Anne qui est initié
pour exorciser les posséder la proie du
diable est un film horrifique mais assez
original de par ces thèmes plutôt
innovants par exemple la place des
femmes dans l'église ou bien la thérapie
on va regarder tout de suite un extrait
de la bande-annonce
certains d'entre vous le savent déjà
nous avons une femme qui vient étudier
dans cette classe seulement
en tant descendons dans les entrailles
de l'enfer si vous le voulez bien
il y a plus de possession signalées de
nos jours que dans toutes les autres
époques de l'histoire nous devons
combattre pour sauver chaque âme
[Musique]
défunt nous dans le combat contre les
esprits de la malveillance
on vous sent pas bien Mathilde
malaise et angoisse c'est les promesses
du film donc à me sensible s'abstenir
on poursuit avec la conspiration du
coeur du réalisateur Tarik a laissé le
thriller de la semaine il vous plonge en
plein conflit politique et religieux au
cœur de l'université islamique à Lazare
du Caire Adam fils de pêcheur réussi à
intégrer la prestigieuse université lieu
central du pouvoir de l'islam sunnite
une sorte de Harvard de du Coran mais
lorsque le grand Imane à la tête de
cette institution décès de le jour même
de la rentrée Adam va se retrouver à son
insu en plein milieu d'une guerre
d'influence pour trouver son successeur
c'est un film à suspense un thriller
d'espionnage à l'intrigue complexe pris
du scénario à Cannes qui vous tiendra en
haleine jusqu'à la dernière image deux
films un peu sombre mais il y a aussi la
comédie un peu plus de légèreté
maintenant on va parler d'une comédie
française l'équipe de barbecue et de
retour pour plancha Derrick Laven pour
ce nouveau film on prend les mêmes ou
presque et on recommence Lambert Wilson
Franck Dubosc Guillaume de ton carrec et
Jérôme Commandeur reviennent donc après
8 ans après les Cévennes du premier opus
direction la Bretagne où nos compères se
réjouissent de fêter les 50 ans de leur
ami Yves avec les Landes à perte de vue
les vieilles pierres les plages de sable
fin le fest-noz tout est en apparence
prévue pour un séjour
idyllique sauf bien sûr Bretagne
Bretagne oblige et ben le beau temps qui
n'est pas présent
urbaines c'est une légende urbaine et
donc sur place la cohabitation s'annonce
un petit peu compliqué les amis de
toujours pourrait bien se brouiller lors
d'importantes révélations on va regarder
aussi un extrait de la bande-annonce
vous inquiétez pas c'est la Bretagne il
y a toujours plein de trucs à faire la
palourde se situe à la limite du sable
sec mais
tu fais quoi maintenant je me suis
inscrite à un cours de sculpture
tu travailles toujours pas quoi
je me suis fait piquer par le guêpe une
guêpe en Bretagne vise ma couille elle a
un cousin qui s'est fait piquer au parti
comme toi il a gonflé gonflé gonflé et
il est mort c'est Jean-Michel et enfin
dernier film pour les plus jeunes
peut-être l'école est à nous une comédie
signée Alexandre Castagnetti alors
autour de cette table qui n'a jamais
rêvé de pouvoir faire ce qu'il voulait à
l'école et bien eux ils l'ont fait alors
l'histoire c'est centre autour d'une
professeur de mathématiques un peu
excentrique qui va profiter d'une grève
générale dans un collège pour tenter un
concept inédit donné à ses élèves cartes
branches et leur laisser faire ce qu'ils
veulent c'est un film qui questionne
l'éducation et l'école avec humour et
optimisme vous préférez quel film autour
de cette table je dirais le dernier j'ai
bien envie de voir le dernier l'école
non non toujours pas d'horreur moi je
dirais peut-être effectivement l'école
est à nous ouais il y a des belles
valeurs qui sont qui sont discutées non
je pense que ça et vous du coup
voilà la comédie avec Franck Dubosc
j'aime beaucoup Franck Dubosc merci
Céline vous m'avez en tout cas à donner
envie d'aller au cinéma dans les
prochains jours on termine par là météo
[Musique]
ce jeudi il fera donc plutôt beau dans
les Yvelines le ciel sera partiellement
couvert dans le Nord et le Sud du
département les températures seront
plutôt douces pour la saison le matin il
faudra 16 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie et
Versailles 15 degrés à Houdan et
Rambouillet l'après-midi le temps sera
également couvert sur l'ensemble du
département de Rambouillet
Mantes-la-Jolie on pourra quand même
sortir en T-shirt l'après-midi il fera
22 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie et 21 degrés
à Rambouillet des températures bien
au-dessus des normales de saison et
demain nous fêterons la sainte Émeline
alors c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de l'avoir suivi merci Céline
merci Mathilde pour toutes ces
chroniques et toutes ces interventions
dans ce 7 8 je vous souhaite une très
belle soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]